[Music]
so
this is really a two-hour presentation i
give to high school students cut down to
three minutes and it all started one day
on a plane on my way to ted seven years
ago and in the seat next to me was a
high school student a teenager and she
came from a really poor family and she
wanted to make something of her life and
she asked me a simple little question
she said what leads to success
and i felt really badly because i
couldn't give her a good answer so i get
off the plane and i come to ted and i
think geez i'm in the middle of a room
of successful people so why don't i ask
them what helped them succeed and pass
it on to kids
so here we are seven years 500
interviews later and i'm going to tell
you what really leads to success and
makes testers tick and the first thing
is passion
freeman thomas says i'm driven by my
passion
testers do it for love they don't do it
for money carol coletta says i would pay
someone to do what i do the interesting
thing is if you do it for love the money
comes anyway
work rupert murdoch said to me it's all
hard work nothing comes easily but i
have a lot of fun
did he say fun rupert
yes
tedsters do have fun working and they
work hard i figured they're not
workaholics they're work of frolicks
good
alex garden says to be successful put
your nose down in something and get damn
good at it there's no magic it's
practice practice practice and its focus
norma jewison said to me i think it all
has to do with focusing yourself on one
thing
and push
david gallo says push yourself
physically mentally you've got to push
push push
you've got to push through shyness and
self-doubt goldie han says i always had
self-doubts i wasn't good enough i
wasn't smart enough i didn't think i'd
make it
now it's not always easy to push
yourself and that's why they invented
mothers
frank geary
frank geary said to me my mother pushed
me
serve
sherwin newland says it was a privilege
to serve as a doctor
now a lot of kids tell me they want to
be millionaires and the first thing i
say to them is okay well you can't serve
yourself you've got to serve others
something of value because that's the
way people really get rich
ideas tedster bill gates says i had an
idea
founding the first microcomputer
software company i'd say it was a pretty
good idea
and there's no magic to creativity in
coming up with ideas it's just doing
some very simple things and i give lots
of evidence
persist
joe crouch says persistence is the
number one reason for our success
you got to persist through failure you
got to persist through crap which of
course means criticism rejection
and pressure
so the big ant the answer to this
question is simple
pay four thousand bucks and come to ted
or failing that do the eight things and
trust me these are the big eight things
that lead to success thank you testers
for all your interviews
[Applause]
you